foreign
has got to be one of the best design
characters in The Tekken franchise
who's introduced in Tekken 5 and has
returned for all subsequent games
it's got this Chinese martial arts a
highly devastating and aggressive style
that is equally athletic as it is
powerful
many players easily had Fang as one of
their favorites because of his beautiful
fighting style and is very fun to play
including of course the creator of
Tekken parata
takes the round with a perfect get ready
for another ochodo TV special this is
the story of fengue
[Music]
a Chinese Kenpo Master as a disciple of
the god fist style by 20 he was the top
student in his dojo when his master
scolded him for fighting outside the
school Feng killed him to retrieve the
secrets of godfist Scrolls stolen by the
mishimas
joins the king of Iron Fist tournament
5.
[Music]
oh yes
losing transmission
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
same way
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description
[Music]
thank you